hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
this is a message for deal sources
and investors that are paying to your
sources there's a couple things
that need to stop and it needs to stop
right now so if you're a deal sourcer
or if you're a property investor you
need to watch this video i've been
packaging and selling deals now for many
years i've packaged and sold
loads of deals i've bought loads of
deals i've paid deal sources to find my
money
and it can be really smooth it's such a
beautiful thing but it can go so
drastically wrong
i've been talking to deal sources and
they've been saying investors are
wasting my time i'm dealing with all
these
you know stupid investors they're
wasting my time
they're saying they want a deal then
they're changing their minds they're
saying
and and that's a problem okay so deal
sources i'm gonna tell you how to stop
that problem but then i'm also speaking
to investors
that are saying i paid a deal source of
money and the deal's rubbish
now i'm struggling to get my money back
geez i wish i just found a deal myself
you know and that's a real big problem
as well real big problem as well so
how how do how do we solve this problem
well the answer is really simple number
one although people won't like me saying
this
people will get upset with me you know
deal sources would get upset with me but
here's the here's the reality
of it do not pay
somebody else to find you a deal
because you're incompetent of finding a
deal
yourself that's it what do i mean by
that
i mean you should not pay somebody to
find you a deal
because you don't know how to find a
deal why why should you not do that
because
the deal saucer might pull the wall over
your eyes
deal saucer might say a deal is great
they might exaggerate the figures that's
how you get screwed
because you don't know what you're doing
yourself the deal saucer
might not try and screw you over but
they might
be ignorant they might think the deal is
great because the estate agent told them
is great but actually
the deal sucks now they're trying to
sell you at the deal and trying to make
three thousand pounds
and the deal sucks so if you're an
investor what's the solution
only pay a deal saucer to find you a
deal
if you've got the skills the knowledge
the expertise the experience whatever
to be able to find a deal and do it
yourself but you're paying a deal saucer
because you just can't be bothered
because you haven't got the time
because time is money i pay deal sources
but the reason i pay deal sources
confidently and comfortably is because
when i pay a deal source or a fee i know
that
i'm not paying them blindly or it's not
blind leading the blind
i pay deal sources sometimes they're
starting out sometimes it'll be their
first deal i'll pay them
because why because i'll number one i'll
know what the terms and conditions
should say so that i'm protected when i
give them my money
and number two when i have the details
and look at the details
if the property is bad i know it's bad
so for me i'm happy to pay a deal source
of 3000 pounds
if it's gonna mean that i don't have to
waste time you know driving all around
up north
viewing lots of houses talking with all
these agents talking with vendors
geez if they find me a house is worth
150 grand and they get at me for 120
grand that's a 30 000 pound saving and
the return on investment is good
i'll pay them three grand okay so
investors
don't pay a deal sourcer unless
you know what you're doing yourself or
you've got a business partner that knows
what they're doing themselves
independent people look at the deals
that's where investors get screwed
another thing is be really careful when
you're investing in a deal source sir
who's packaging rent to rent
i'm not saying it's not possible i'm not
saying it can't work but i've seen it
fail so many times
because rent to rent is a business you
need to remember when you're buying a
rent to rent deal off somebody
you're buying into a business
it's not just going to be passive if you
don't understand how to run that
business
and you haven't got the the knowledge or
the expertise to run the business
you're buying a business which is going
to fail and it's not necessarily the
deal
sources fault you know it might be that
it's a really good rent to rent
the fault is the fact that you just
don't know how to run the rent to rent
business so be
really careful buying rent to rent deals
off deal sources
be really careful buying anything from
deal sources in fact just don't do it at
all
unless you know what you're doing
yourself that's the first point
that's my point to investors now my next
point
is to deal sources okay
if you're a deal so let me know in the
comments let me know if you're a deal
saucer
or your investor let me know i want to
know do i have more people watching my
channel who are investors
who are looking to invest money and buy
properties or do i have more people who
are
wanting to be deal sources that don't
necessarily have the money themselves to
invest
so they're wanting to package up a deal
and sell it let me know in the comments
your deal source or an investor
if you're a deal sourcer here's here's
the thing do not
sell a property to somebody unless
number one it's a good deal that you
would be prepared to pa
buy it yourself okay don't sell bad
deals don't try and make a quick book
only sell deals to people that you would
buy yourself now you might be thinking
but samuel
if you'd buy it yourself then what would
you sell it at all but because you
haven't got the money
or because it's like when you when
you're a private when you're a property
investor you should be a deal sorcerer
it's like
waiting for a bus you wait for a bus not
that i've done that for a very long time
but you went for a bus and then suddenly
three come at once right
so when you're deal sources sometimes
you'd be like you know you're waiting
for a deal to come along for yourself
and you look in and you're searching and
you're talking and you're negotiating
and then suddenly you get three deals
but you don't want to buy three deals
you just want to buy one
so what are you gonna do with the other
two what are you gonna sell them so only
sell deals that are good deals that you
prepared to buy yourself
number two when you sell a deal to an
investor
you need to close the investor
don't let the investor ask you a whole
bunch of questions
and be like let me ask you and spend an
hour with you on the phone talking about
you know picking your brand about the
deal unless first you've qualified them
so you need to say to the investor look
before i go into details about the house
have you got funds ready to go oh we're
not quite okay cool in that case
next have you got funds ready to go yeah
i got funds ready to go great
and if the deal's right my fee is three
thousand pounds
are you in a position where you buy you
can pay my fee today
if the deal's right oh i wouldn't want
to pay it today
oh i want to talk to my wife and the dog
and you know
my lawyers well okay well this deal
needs to go today next move on
pre-qualify the investor sell the deal
to the investing get the money
up front get the money in the bank
okay somebody tell all of my students is
this and say
they've not been sold if you ain't got
their goals
okay a deal's not sold until you've got
the gold so get the money in the bank
up front give a calling off period
no one's going to give you 5 000 pounds
or even 1 000 pounds for a laugh no
one's going to
here's here's three grand for a deal and
then go the next day i change my mind
it's very very very rare
so you're gonna get the money get a
calling off period
and then show them all the details
have dinner with them take them out to
the property and
if the property is good and you find a
good deal
they won't ask for their money back in
those 14 days
get good terms and conditions after 14
days
um if the deal falls through then
you need strong season seasons to take
exactly all the ifs and bursts what's
going to happen
depend on it depends if it's their fault
if it's the fault of the house
or whatever so get good terms and
conditions learn to sell learn to close
get money up front
get money up front um no messing you
know i spoke to a guy yesterday i was on
clubhouse
i was in a clubhouse and the guy was
saying that he's been in the game for
eight months
and he um he can't sell
every time he sells a deal he says it
falls through i said why is it falling
through it goes because the investor
pulls out the last minute i'm like but
have you got his fee
his money no i don't take the money
until completion i'm like well no wonder
you're dealing with time wasters you
need to get the money up front
so basically if you're an investor
you need to be very careful around deal
sources and you need to make sure
that everything is proper if you're a
deal source you need to be very careful
of investors
because they can waste your time and say
they want to buy deal and then pull out
the day before completion
leaving you with nothing you've got to
be very careful you've got the money up
front
have terms and conditions that cover you
both so that's basically it i'm running
a property investors crash course
i've been in the game now 12 years folks
12 years
i've done over 300 deals i've got the
largest
training company in the uk for property
investors i'm running a property
investors crash course i'm going to
teach everything i know about property
in 12 hours on a virtual crash course
and guess what it's free so if you want
to come down i'll leave a link in the
description
get booked on it's coming soon it's free
and i hope you enjoyed the video
subscribe smash the like button
drop a comment and book on the crash
course i'll see you there